earlier this year warren buffett the
greatest investor of our lifetime was
asked about inflation and he issued a
massive warning he said prepare now for
huge inflation to be coming warren was
using all sorts of data points inside of
his companies seeing their costs rising
and also passing on a lot of those costs
to their consumers and raising their
prices here's exactly what warren had to
say in his issuance of this warning back
earlier of 2022. we're seeing very
substantial inflation it's very
interesting we're raising prices people
are raising prices to us it's being
accepted i mean it's not you know take
home building i mean you know the cost
of we've got nine home builders in
addition to our manufactured housing and
then uh operation which is the largest
in the country so we really do a lot of
housing
the costs are just up up up
steel costs just every day uh
they're they're going up and that
there hasn't yet been because the wage
the wage stuff follows i mean if the uaw
writes a three-year contract we got a
three-year contract but if you're buying
steel
at general motors or some place you're
paying more every day
so it's an economy really
it's red hot i mean and we weren't
expecting it i mean all our companies
when they they thought when we're
allowed to go back to work you know with
our various operations we closed the
furniture stores i mentioned you know if
they were closed for six weeks or so on
average and they didn't know what was
going to happen when they
when they open up and you know
they can't stop people from buying
things
and we can't deliver them and they say
well that's okay because nobody else can
deliver meter and we'll wait for three
months or something to start of the
backlog grows and then we thought it
would end when the 600
payments ended and i think you know
around august of last year it just kept
going and it keeps going and it keeps
going and it keeps going uh people have
money in their pocket and and they pay
the higher prices and when
carpet prices go up
in a month or two you know we announced
the price increase for april for our
cluster going up supply chains all
screwed up you know for all kinds of
people but
it's almost a buying frenzy except
certain areas you can't buy it you know
everybody can't buy international air
travel and there's
so the money is being diverted from a
little from a piece of the economy into
the rest and everybody's got
more cash in their pocket than except
for meanwhile you know it's a terrible
situation for
a percentage of the people there's
there's more inflation going on than
quite a bit more inflation going on than
people would have anticipated just six
months ago or there abouts
now what is fascinating about this is
that when warren buffett issued this
warning everyone thought that meant that
cpi would just continue to go up and up
and up but it hasn't actually cpi went
from 9.1
to 8.5 in july and all of a sudden the
critics they started to celebrate
inflation was coming down right wrong we
are now entering into a phase known as
the base effect last year starting in
june all the way through the end of the
year the cpi inflation number went from
five to over seven percent so this year
as we continue to see very high
inflation it's on top of last year's
high numbers this is a compounding
effect meaning that inflation is not
just up 8.5
it's up 8.5
on top of the 5 it was up last year that
base effect means that we should expect
the cpi number to come down but
inflation is still here and it is still
punishing the people who are most
vulnerable in our society warren buffett
was right that we should prepare for
huge inflation as the federal reserve
continues to tighten financial
conditions they are going to try to
bring that number down but just because
the cpi number actually comes down
doesn't mean that we're going to roll
back the price increases or that the
average american family will be in a
better position add in things like
supply chain disruptions and the current
geopolitical chess that is playing out
on the continent of europe and now you
can see how we are starting to enter
into an energy crisis going into the
winter months there's a lot of
complexity there's a lot of uncertainty
but inflation is still a massive problem
eventually the federal reserve will run
out of ammo they can't continue to raise
interest rates forever unless they want
to bankrupt the united states of america
and so naturally at some point the fed
will wave the white flag they will pivot
and they will return to loose monetary
policy the question is how much can they
get inflation under control before they
hit that moment i don't have those
answers but somebody like warren buffett
who has so much information at his
fingertips and sees so much of the data
coming from his own companies if he's
issuing warnings about huge inflation on
the horizon i would listen if i was you
hey you did you like this video great
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time